foreign
[Music]
cancer action Network's Raleigh Durham
affiliate I'm a volunteer here in
Central North Carolina and I work with a
team of volunteers that consists of
survivors caregivers family members and
Health Care Professionals and our
mission is to support pain can's goals
of raising awareness for pancreatic
cancer and raising funds to for Research
into early detection and better
treatment options for our patients I'm
here today to share a little bit about
my experiences share a little bit about
pan can and what they have to offer to
our patients and our Healthcare
Community and lastly to really emphasize
the fact that together working together
as a team is what's going to help
transform the future for our patients
so a little bit about pan can well nope
let's start about me first a little bit
about my story and actually it's not
just my story it's my father's story and
my family story
my father was 66 years old when he was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer he had
never been sick a day in his life he was
incredibly healthy went for annual
checks up checkups and had his blood
work done and always got a clean and
good bill of health
in the summer of 2001 he started having
some vague symptoms and his story is
very similar to hundreds of stories I've
heard over the years
he had vague symptoms of stomach issues
of fatigue and lower back pain
it was the fatigue that bothered him the
most as you can see this is the last
family picture we took he had five
grandchildren who were very young at the
time and he loved spending time with him
the fatigue is what really made him go
to the doctor to find out what was
happening and like many many many others
who are eventually diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer these vague symptoms
were misdiagnosed they thought he had an
ulcer he went on ulcer medicine and to
make a long story short in the end he
was finally diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer
of course we were devastated my family
was familiar with pancreatic cancer
ten years prior we had a very close
family friend diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer and succumbed to the disease we
knew how devastating it was but I think
what was even more devastating was the
fact that in that 10-year period there
had been little to no progress done for
this disease
a short six and a half weeks after my
father was diagnosed he died from
pancreatic cancer again I can't
emphasize how devastated we were as a
family how grief stricken we were how
angry and frustrated we were and we took
all of that and decided to put it into
action and we reached out to the
pancreatic cancer Action Network and
started our affiliate here in Central
North Carolina we were one of the very
first Affiliates Across the Nation to
work with pan can and again our goal is
to raise awareness and funding for
better research for more treatment
options for an early detection method so
that other families do not have to
travel the path we have and that their
outcome is far better than ours was for
my dad
so a little bit about pan can
we we know we are taking on one of the
world's toughest Cancers and at pan can
we have our efforts are divided up into
four categories
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about each one of these as we go through
the presentation but research and quick
clinical initiatives being in has
pioneered and pushed science forward
through our nationally acclaimed grants
program
our own initiative on clinical studies
and the cultivation of a thriving
research committee a community so we are
funding transformative research early
detection and better treatment options
and again I'll talk a little bit about
the initiatives on the next slide
government advocacy is another big
initiative at pancan and this is where
volunteers are critically important in
this effort
can can demands Federal funding for
research and we advocate for legislative
support for lifting up our voices to
keep pancreatic cancer at the Forefront
on Capitol Hill
and I'm going to show you a picture of
some volunteers out on Capitol Hill back
in 2019 we've done it virtually the last
couple of years but our last in-person
efforts up in DC was in 2019.
then we have patient services we've
revolutionized the approach to treating
pancreatic cancer by connecting patients
with the latest treatment options and we
provide free in-depth disease
information and free is the key word
here our patient services is available
to everyone to our survivors our
patients our caregivers and the Health
Care community and it is a free service
that is available to you
and then lastly there's Community
engagement another area where our
volunteers are critically involved and
do a great effort to to advance
pancreatic cancer awareness and then the
need for funding for research projects
so um we lead and mobilize communities
Across the Nation to raise greater
awareness and funds today there are 60
plus Affiliates Across the Nation where
a Vibrant Community of volunteers
caregivers family members Health Care
Professionals we work year-round raising
awareness for not just pancreatic cancer
but for the pancreatic cancer Action
Network itself and then again the needs
for funding into research where
Grassroots organization of volunteers
working in communities in honor of our
loved ones lost to this disease and we
are dedicated in the fight to end
pancreatic cancer one day
so a little bit more specific about the
initiatives at pan can as you can see on
the left side of this slide pan can is
committed to investing 25 million
dollars this year into research
accumulative
investment to date is 174 million
dollars so we're proud of all of those
numbers but as far as the initiatives we
have a grants program I'm going to talk
about that one first by offering grants
for basic translational and Clinical
Research in pancreatic cancer to
scientists and clinicians at various
career levels can accelerates progress
in the fight against the Disease by
advancing research towards the goals of
improving patient outcomes
since 2003 pancan has awarded
234 grants to 213 scientists at 79
institutions through a rigorous peer
review process
and as you can see this year alone we're
committed to 25 million and that has
been a consistent number or a roughly
that number the last few years
we have an emphasis on early career
investigators and this fundraising
growth you see here indicates that we
are building a pipeline of pancreatic
canister investigators researchers are
staying in the field and we are
leveraging our donors dollars to advance
progress
cancan is currently accepting
applications for the 2023 uh Career
Development Awards
recipients of these Awards received 250
000 and uh they will be announced in the
spring and then uh in the summer of
um uh next summer our programs will open
for the 2024 grants so there are several
opportunities for Grants through pancan
early detection targeted grants
Precision medicine targeted grants
research acceleration translational
research all of these can be found on
paincan.org Research so if you go to
pancan.org research and I'll have our
um I'll have that information on one of
my later slides toward the end of the
presentation if you go out on our
website you can read about each one of
these grants you can see who the grant
recipients were in the past couple of
years and then all the information is
there how to apply for these grants
so at pancam we also have uh know your
tumor so pancans know your tumor
Precision medicine research program
provides eligible pancreatic cancer
patients and their oncologists with
information about their biology through
biomarker testing of tumor tissue and
genetic testing for inherited mutations
know your tumor gives patients and their
health care team access to information
about treatments including available
clinical trials that are personalized to
them Reserve results from know your
tumor have shown that patients who are
eligible to receive treatment that
matches their tumor biology live an
average of one year longer than patients
want
next we have pants pancans patient
registry this is a global online
database created to look for patterns
and treatments side effect management
and Diagnostics that will lead to
improved treatment options and outcomes
for patients
by joining this quickly growing
community and sharing experiences
participants give researchers access to
critical data that will help make
discoveries
this information provided is completely
secure the user decides who sees the
information how it will be used and if
they want to be contacted by researchers
learnings from the patient registry have
been published and presented at Major
biomedical conferences describing the
appropriate use of pancreatic enzymes
and management of patient symptoms and
side effects
okay next another initiative we have is
called spark our spark data platform
um spark our Healthcare data integration
platform gives qualified researchers
secure and open access to de-identified
Patient data so they can learn from and
build on each other's discoveries spark
breaks down the traditional barriers to
accelerating research to give us to get
us closer to answers better treatments
for pancreatic cancer and ultimately
improved survival
spark will integrate data from pan cans
programs and services like know your
tumor as well as subsets of data from
our large-scale initiatives like
Precision promise and early detection
initiative
so next is that early detection
initiative this is a randomized trial to
develop a feasible and cost effective
approach using Imaging in a high risk
new onset diabetes population to detect
pancreatic cancer when it can be
surgically removed
this transformative program aims to
rapidly accelerate progress to develop
an early detection strategy for
pancreatic cancer
and so working in collaboration with
government and research institutions
this early detection initiative is a
unique opportunity to analyze patients
blood and I and other bio specimens for
pancreatic cancer cancer biomarkers in a
multi
multi-institutional study
in conjunction in a designated subset of
patients we will use existing Imaging
and accelerate the development of
improved imaging technology to allow
doctors to catch the cancer sooner when
lesions are smaller our best opportunity
of helping our patients
live a full and complete life
and then lastly you'll see there is a
Precision promise
and precision promises a groundbreaking
new approach to pancreatic cancer
clinical trials and it's created to
speed progress for patients by getting
new and better treatments approved more
quickly
with a team of more than a hundred
expert clinicians researchers and
Diagnostic and key and and key drug
developers
um and with the generous funding from
Visionary donors pain cans Precision
promise is open to eligible patients to
enroll at world-class cancer
institutions Nationwide
and precision promise is different than
standard clinical trials because it has
an Adaptive design the Adaptive design
allows for multiple treatments to be
tested simultaneously fewer patients are
required determined to determine if a
treatment is working so it takes less
time and it costs less money the design
of the trial was approved by the FDA and
seen as a model for clinical trials into
the future
so the next slide I included because it
just I think it's a great visual of how
our money is being used and leveraged in
the research Community for every dollar
that pan can invest it's been shown that
grantees go on to receive an additional
11.50 and subsequent uh pancreatic
cancer funding and this is critical this
is a goal of pan cans to increase that
research funding so we're um we're proud
to be a part of these efforts
so we'll talk a little bit about the
five-year survive survival rate for
pancreatic cancer in 2001 and prior um
in 2001 when my dad was diagnosed the
survival five-year survival rate was
four percent and at the time uh
somebody's got to be in that four
percent and we were fighting hard to
make sure that he was part of that four
percent unfortunate and he was willing
to fight as well unfortunately the odds
were stacked against him
um today we have seen that uh rate
increase to double digits it's good news
um we continue to see this number rise
in the right direction but it is still
just way too low and uh reflects the
much needed progress that much needed
progress is needed to improve outcomes
for for our patients and as I said
earlier pancreatic cancer is one of the
world's toughest cancers it is currently
the third leading cause of cancer deaths
in the United States so it demands
urgent acts action to save lives and our
survivors are the best ones to Advocate
on their own behalf and unfortunately we
don't have a lot of survivors and that's
where the rest of us need to fill this
Gap and Nationwide this year there'll be
over 62
000 Americans diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer and unfortunately there would be
50 000
approximately 50 000 deaths so it is
critically important that we continue to
team together
our efforts have driven this five-year
survival rate from 4 to 11 today and at
pancan our goal is to improve this rate
to 20 by 2030.
so
um partnering for Progress together we
can improve the progress of our patients
um you know often uh once diagnosed
patients will turn to the internet to to
find the information
um that they need and this can
unfortunately result in inaccurate and
hard to understand information and and
mostly feelings of really deep
hopelessness
um and so at pancam we are um we are
trying to help give information to our
patients and um to our Health Care
Professionals and to help our caregivers
as they as they journey through this
diagnosis of pancreatic cancer our
services are free once again we welcome
you to encourage your patients to access
all that we have available at pancan and
we encourage each and every one of you
to also access this free information
that is available and the one-on-one
support that is available to our
patients as a patient calls in or a
caregiver calls in they will be assigned
to a case manager who will work with
them to give them the resources that
they need on their journey through this
cancer diagnosis
um just once again that the offerings
that we have
through pan can patients and Healthcare
professionals have this free access to
personalized support for anything
related to pancreatic cancer
um you are connected to a case manager
who will work with you continuously
through the resources that you need in
the in your journey
and now that the national Comprehensive
Cancer Network recommends genetic
testing and tumor profiling for all
pancreatic cancer patients paint cans
know your tumor Precision medicine
service is even more crucial
so we have a Survivor and caregiver
Network where we advocate for our
patients and connect and match them with
others in their in their situation no
one should face cancer alone and so
cancan believes that all patients and
caregiver caregivers should have the
support they need and face their Journey
with hope and so we have this uh
available as well
as well as
um information and you can see a couple
of the booklets that we have these again
all free
um and we encourage uh all to reach out
to pan can if you need additional
information and we are here for you and
um we have a trove of information
available to you
okay so I think pictures do a fabulous
uh fabulous way of explaining what we do
better than I can in this presentation
as I mentioned earlier a part of our
advocacy work goes on year round but
June is a very special month for us June
is when we descend on Capitol Hill for
our advocacy day and uh you can see we
are a sea of purple
um purple is the color for pancreatic
cancer typically we are in person the
picture on the top is the last time we
were in person in Washington DC in 2019
and at that that year there were over
650 volunteers survivors caregivers and
Health Care Professionals that descended
on DC and we are incredibly proud of the
efforts that we in enact every every
June in DC you can see the the picture
on the bottom is what we've done
recently in most recent years our
average advocacy day and our efforts
have been virtually they too have been
successful though
um you know pancan is is successful in
driving legislative support for
increased Federal research funding which
is critical because 80 percent of
pancreatic cancer research funding comes
from a federal source
together we're making progress and we're
seeing success we're teaming with Health
Care Professionals who now join us on
Capitol Hill and that has made a
difference
sharing their experiences and progress
in the research field has resulted in
increased funding that will transform
the future of pancreatic cancer in the
future for our pancreatic cancer
patients
together we have helped increase NCI
pancreatic cancer research funding from
just 17 million in 1999 when pancam was
founded
to over a hundred and eighty two million
in 2018 and so I think that's worth
repeating 17 million
20 some odd years ago to a hundred and
eighty two million in 2018 and this is
an increase of almost a thousand percent
and that's due to the ongoing efforts by
all of our volunteers
we're also were very successful in
getting the recalcitation cancer
research act signed into law in January
of 2013. this resulted in the NCI making
pancreatic cancer cancer a national
priority and developing us just
strategic plan for the disease
so one of the next uh really important
advocacy efforts we have coming up is in
November November is pancreatic cancer
awareness month and so our Affiliates
Across the Nation will be having all
kinds of events uh during the month of
November and also November 17th is World
pancreatic cancer day so we will
absolutely have a lot of activity on
November 17th
and I've also shared a picture the
picture on the right is one of our
Patient Advocates and I purposely put
that picture there because patient
advocacy comes in all shapes and sizes
you are never too old and you are
definitely never too young to advocate
for a pancreatic cancer patients and
this picture was taken at our purple
stride event this past April we have an
event this is our signature event every
year
where we raise awareness and funding for
pan can and we this year were a sea of
about uh 1200 in 2019 which was our last
in-person event we had well over 2 000
so we're building up again and look
forward to our purple stride event in
April 29 on April 29 of 2023 there will
be 60 plus purple strides Across the
Nation so I encourage you to look for a
purple stride near you
um next year
and now we talked about how important
the healthcare professionals are in our
patient advocacy work and I really want
to highlight a couple of people that
have made a significant difference in
our community here in North Carolina but
a significant diff difference to our
pancreatic cancer patients so first I
want to highlight drank Antonio Baines
Dr Baines is a professor at North North
Carolina's Central University in Durham
North Carolina Dr Baines has graciously
opened his lab for tours for our
volunteers and our donors and the
general public he's also had a lecture
Series where he's
presented on the work that he is doing
and what's happening in the research
field and we are very grateful for to
hear from him it means a lot to those of
us that are volunteering and donating to
the cause to hear what is happening and
so we we thank Dr Baines for his
continued advocacy work he does a great
job of keeping
um our pancreatic cancer in the news
he's he's written articles in our print
media locally and he's also been on a TV
interviewed for the work that he is
doing and we are proud to call him a
friend of our affiliate
next we have Dr Kirsten Bryant
Dr Bryant is a professor at the
Lineberger Comprehensive Cancer Center
at UNC Chapel Hill now Dr Ryan has a
really unique uh kind of take on the
work that we are all doing while she was
studying for her PhD she lost her father
to pancreatic cancer and so she has
dedicated her life's work to pancreatic
cancer research she is a fabulous
advocate for us she comes with us up to
Washington every June to advocate for
pancreatic cancer research her
experience and expertise has been I've
seen firsthand how it has made a
difference in the work we are doing when
we are advocating for our patients she
is also on the media here in our local
market we have a great relationship with
one of our anchors on the major TV
station here and he when I coordinate
with him during November or in April
when we're highlighting our purple stuff
Pride event he is always asking for Dr
Bryant because she's a great
communicator and into the fabulous job
of sharing her work and how meaningful
it is to our patients and and what she
is doing so we're proud to call her
friend friend and we're grateful for her
as well
and then next we have Dr darsh kathari
Dr kathari is a gastroenterologist at
Duke Health in Durham North Carolina
he has been a speaker at many of our
events he shares with us the work that
he is doing and um the screening that he
does for his patients that might be
candidates for pancreatic cancer he also
brings his team out you can see them
there in the other picture he brings his
team out to our purple stride event this
was this past April of 2022 where they
came out to volunteer they sponsor our
event they are great supporters and we
are grateful for all the work that they
do for our patients and uh for our cause
so we're proud of Dr kathari and his
team in their work too
and so a couple of you know just to end
the presentation couple of thoughts
we're here for you I hope you've heard
that um in my presentation we're here
for you for whatever you need
um please do not hesitate to reach out
I'll have my con contact information in
the next slide or two you are welcome to
contact me as well but please go to
pancan.org for Health Care Professionals
there is a a an unending amount of
information out there I have only hit
the tip of the iceberg of what's
available not only to our patients but
to you as health care providers and I
welcome you to go out there and read
about all that's available there's also
a phone number there for you to use that
number
um is the general number for pan can
that we give out to everyone when you
call that number you'll be directed to
the right person to answer your
questions to give you the information
you need
um so please we're here for you
and we're also here for Joanne
Joanne is a seven year pancreatic cancer
survivor and I just love this picture
again pictures speak volumes I think you
can see the grit the determination
um on Joanne and our family and
supporters they are determined to help
Joanne live a full and complete life and
so are we and I hope you will join me
too in helping Joanne but not only
Joanne but that there are more Joannes
across this nation and um I I just hope
and I thank you for for all the work you
are doing I I thank you for your
advocacy for our patients you are going
to be the key uh to ending pancreatic
cancer one day and I can't thank you
enough for your efforts
and then lastly again uh here's my
contact information again I'm Liz
Johnson affiliate chair of the Raleigh
Durham North Carolina pancreatic cancer
Action Network uh here for you as well
please don't hesitate to reach out to me
if you have any specific questions I
thank you for this opportunity I am
incredibly grateful for each and every
one of you and I appreciate the work
that you do not only for pancreatic
cancer for
um for all our cancer cancer patients so
thank you again for this opportunity